Cuando Nancy Pelosi, la presidenta de la Cámara
de Representantes de los Estados Unidos, visitó
Taiwán el día 2 de agosto de 2022, los chinos,
o mejor dicho, en el gobierno chino se volvieron
locos.
El resultado es que el gobierno de Xi Jinping
ha puesto la tensión en la zona al rojo vivo.
De esta forma, además de condenar la visita,
China puso en marcha enormes ejercicios militares,
rodeó la isla y desplegó aviones de guerra
y un montón de barcos.
Incluso, el ejército chino, disparó misiles
balísticos frente a las costas de Taiwán,
y, por primera vez, cuatro de ellos sobrevolaron
la propia isla.
Claro que este tipo de provocaciones no son
algo estrictamente nuevo.
Por ejemplo, las incursiones de la fuerza
aérea china en la Zona de Identificación
de Defensa Aérea de Taiwán son ya algo cotidiano.
Bombarderos, cazas, aviones de vigilancia,
helicópteros...
Por allí pasa de todo constantemente, lo
que obliga a las fuerzas taiwanesas a estar
permanentemente en alerta.
C1("La cuestión de Taiwán ha dejado de ser
una especie de asunto estrecho, de boutique,
y se ha convertido en un teatro central -si
no en el drama central- en la competencia
estratégica entre Estados Unidos y China".
Evan Medeiros, experto en asuntos asiáticos
y miembro del Consejo de Seguridad Nacional
de la Administración Obama)
C2("A medida que los Estados Unidos y las
fuerzas externas, incluidas las fuerzas de
independencia de Taiwán, hagan provocaciones
constantes, los ejercicios serán más intensos
y más frecuentes, más amplios en tiempo
y alcance".
Song Zhongping, analista militar y ex oficial
del ejército chino.)
El caso es que durante los últimos años
la cuestión de Taiwán está cobrando cada
vez más protagonismo en la agenda internacional...
Y especialmente en la agenda del gobierno
chino.
Aquí en VisualPolitik hemos publicado unos
cuantos vídeos sobre este tema: os hemos
hablado, por ejemplo, sobre cómo podría
defenderse Taiwán, sobre qué podría aprender
de Ucrania, sobre las razones que están detrás
de la reivindicación china y de otras muchas
cuestiones por el estilo.
Sin embargo, nos falta responder a unas cuantas
preguntas absolutamente claves:
¿A qué viene tanto interés repentino por
Taiwán?
¿Por qué tras la visita de Pelosi el gobierno
de Xi Jinping perdió de tal forma los papeles?
¿Cuál será el siguiente paso de Pekín?
¿A qué riesgo se enfrenta realmente Taiwán
en un futuro próximo?
Pues bien vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas, y lo primero, si os parece, es
saber cuáles son los 5 motivos que explican
por qué China parece cada vez más obsesionada
con Taiwán.
Y ya os adelanto que en esta receta tenemos
ingredientes de todo tipo: militares, políticos,
económicos y diplomáticos.
¡Atentos!
T1(UNA CUESTIÓN MADE IN CHINA)
Que el gobierno de Xi Jinping esté elevando
el tono sobre Taiwán no es algo para nada
casual.
Como ya os he dicho, son al menos 5 los motivos
que explican esta virulenta reacción.
Y, ¿sabéis qué?
Los dos primeros tienen mucho que ver con
la propia política de Xi Jinping.
(En primer lugar, a finales del 2022 el líder
chino desafiará la hasta ahora tradicional
limitación de mandatos del Partido Comunista
chino.
De esta forma se asegurará seguir al frente
del país durante al menos un tercer mandato.
Esto es algo que no ocurría desde la época
de Mao.
Pero, amigos, Xi Jinping no quiere abandonar
el poder.
)
Y claro, no hay nada mejor para legitimar
su posición que promover un discurso tremendamente
nacionalista y presentarse como el líder
que devolverá a China toda su grandeza.
En ese caso el líder que por fin puso a Hong
Kong bajo el control total de Pekín, y que
próximamente lo hará con Taiwán.
Claro que, un momento, porque ese no es el
único objetivo del creciente nacionalismo
del gobierno chino.
La otra razón tiene mucho que ver con desviar
la atención de algo que ya os hemos contado
aquí en VisualPolitik.
(La economía china no está atravesando su
mejor momento.
Salvando el coronavirus su crecimiento es
el más bajo en 30 años, el desempleo joven
no deja de crecer y el país está al borde
de sufrir una enorme crisis económica y quizás
también financiera.)
En otras palabras, que con Xi Jinping la prosperidad
china se está derrumbando.
Y con ello también lo está haciendo el histórico
pacto tácito entre el Partido Comunista y
la sociedad china:
[ya sabéis eso de: vosotros no cuestionais
al gobierno ni al partido comunista y a cambio
los mandamases de Pekín os garantizamos prosperidad
y una rápida mejora en los niveles de vida.]
Y la pregunta es, ¿qué hace todo buen político
cuando fracasa en su objetivo fundamental?
Exacto, sacarse otro de la chistera.
Cuando la economía va de mal en peor no resulta
extraño que los políticos se inventen de
repente otras reivindicaciones.
En este caso de una agenda mucho más nacionalista,
lo que incluye el tema de Taiwán.
De repente para el gobierno chino el crecimiento
y la prosperidad parece haber dejado de ser
una prioridad.
Ahora lo que importa es recuperar la grandeza
de la gran nación china.
Lo que Xi Jingping conoce como “el gran
rejuvenecimiento nacional”.
[A pesar de que, bueno, China cada vez tiene
una población más envejecida.]
De hecho, la burbuja inmobiliaria comenzó
a explotar cuando Evergrande, una de las grandes
promotoras inmobiliarias chinas, se vino abajo.
El colapso de esta compañía comenzó a ser
bien conocido, al menos públicamente, aproximadamente
a partir del mes de septiembre del 2021.
Pues, fijaos en lo que Xi Jinping decía al
poco tiempo.
N1(11 de octubre del 2021: Xi Jinping dice
que la reunificación es imprescindible para
el rejuvenecimiento de China.
Europa Press)
Ya lo veis, es una cuestión de puro interés
político.
Claro que junto a estos, también podemos
encontrar motivos de corte militar, económico
y diplomático.
Por ejemplo, el tercer motivo por el que Taiwán
despierta de repente tanto interés en Pekín
tiene mucho que ver con la modernización
de las fuerzas armadas de este país.
Veréis, me explico.
Durante los últimos años el ejército chino
se ha modernizado y ha crecido en capacidades.
Así que ahora su objetivo pasa por extender
su influencia por toda la región.
Pues bien, en esta línea Taiwán es algo
así como una llave para acceder tanto al
mar de la China Meridional como al propio
Océano Pacífico.
Dos objetivos necesarios para la operatividad
de la armada china.
De hecho, como veis la isla de Formosa es
el eslabón principal de una cadena de islas
que llegado el caso podría bloquear a la
armada china.
Y eso no es todo, si Taiwán estuviera bajo
dominio chino, además de tener más facilidad
para extender su influencia en la región
conseguiría un control enorme sobre una de
las rutas comerciales más importantes del
planeta.
(El estrecho de Taiwán es una de las rutas
marítimas más concurridas de todo el planeta
. Casi la mitad de los buques contenedores,
incluyendo el 88% de los de clase más grande,
pasan por allí.
Hablamos de la ruta principal para los barcos
que transportan mercancías desde China, Japón
y Corea del Sur hacia el oeste.
Y también, claro está, de la ruta principal
a través de la cual estos mismos países
se abastecen de energía.)
En otras palabras, adversarios de China como
Corea del Sur o Japón dependerían de Pekín
para llevar a término buena parte de sus
exportaciones o aprovisionarse de gas y petróleo.
Y aún más, llegado el caso, Taiwán podría
ser utilizado por Estados Unidos como una
especie de portaaviones y centro de aprovisionamiento.
Si Taiwán volviera a estar bajo control de
Pekín, ese riesgo desaparecería por completo.
Así que visto de esta forma, la presión
china parece una consecuencia lógica del
creciente peso militar del gigante asiático.
Pero, amigos, amigas, aún no hemos terminado.
Como os decía también podemos encontrar
otros dos claros motivos: uno económico y
otro diplomático.
Prestad mucha atención.
T2(UN BLOQUEO DE CHIPS Y UNA MEDIDA DE PRESIÓN
)
La República Popular China lleva años preparando
a sus fuerzas armadas para invadir Taiwán.
Por ejemplo, ha construido la mayor armada
del mundo por número de barcos.
Algo que como veréis puede ser mucho más
importante de lo que podríamos pensar a simple
vista.
Y no sólo eso, el llamado Ejército Popular
de Liberación de la China continental, también
está incrementando y mucho su presencia en
torno a Taiwán.
Sin embargo, el primer paso en un hipotético
conflicto podría ser muy distinto.
En varios vídeos anteriores, aquí en VisualPolitik,
ya os hemos contado cómo Taiwán podría
prepararse para que cualquier invasión tuviera
un coste excesivamente alto para Pekín.
Y la experiencia rusa en Ucrania es, por así
decirlo, toda una llamada de atención.
Por eso, el régimen comunista podría intentar
una estrategia diferente: bloquear la isla
de Formosa y a sus 23 millones de habitantes
por mar y aire.
Es decir, aislar a Taiwán para hacerse con
el control de la situación y obtener concesiones
de Taipei.
Esta estrategia, por cierto, no resulta para
nada casual.
Fijaos en este mapa, la mayor parte de la
población, de la industria y de los puertos
de Taiwán se concentran precisamente en el
flanco occidental de la isla, es decir, justo
frente a las costas de la China continental.
De esta forma, utilizando decenas y decenas,
quizás cientos de barcos de guerra y submarinos,
Pekín podría impedir que los buques mercantes
entraran o salieran de la isla, sellando también
con ello una de las rutas comerciales más
concurridas del mundo y una vía imprescindible
para la economía taiwanesa.
De la misma forma, la enorme superioridad
numérica de las fuerzas aéreas chinas junto
a sus nuevos portaaviones podrían también
permitirles cerrar a cal y canto su espacio
aéreo.
Y algo muy similar podrían hacer también
en gran medida con el ciberespacio.
¿Cómo?
Pues cortando o desactivando los cables submarinos
que transportan en torno al 90% de los datos
que conectan esta isla con el resto del mundo.
(El caso es que un bloqueo de estas características
podría forzar rápidamente una negociación
o disuadir a Taipei de tomar decisiones que
no gusten en Pekín.
Asimismo, al no ser estrictamente una acción
de guerra, o al menos un ataque directo a
la isla, esto podría hacer que Estados Unidos
y otros aliados apostaran por la vía diplomática
como respuesta.
Además, Taiwán tiene una gran dependencia
tanto de las importaciones de combustibles
y alimentos como de las exportaciones que
forman el núcleo central de su economía.
Así que es posible que la isla no pudiera
soportar un bloqueo de estas características
por mucho tiempo, no al menos sin sufrir grandes
pérdidas.)
Y eso no es todo.
Queridos amigos, echad el freno porque justo
aquí tenemos que detenernos un momento.
¿Recordáis qué gran éxito ha tenido la
industria taiwanesa en los últimos años?
3, 2,1.....
¡Exacto!
Taiwán se ha convertido en la Meca de los
chips.
(Los chips son pequeños circuitos integrados
que se han convertido en el componente indispensable
de la evolución tecnológica.
Desde la nanotecnología hasta la robótica,
desde los F-35 hasta los drones pasando por
los smartphones que todos llevamos en nuestro
bolsillo.
Todos los aparatos modernos necesitan de estos
pequeños instrumentos.
En cierta forma la carrera tecnológica, incluyendo,
insisto el campo militar, se ha convertido
en una carrera por hacerse con los mejores
chips.)
Pues, ¿sabéis qué?
Taiwán se ha convertido en el epicentro mundial
de la fabricación de chips avanzados.
Lo que quiere decir, que hoy por hoy Taiwan
es un lugar clave para la industria tecnológica
y la industria militar de Estados Unidos.
Sin embargo, un bloqueo chino podría interrumpir
las cadenas de suministros...
Lo que, como veis, afectaría directamente
a la seguridad nacional de la potencia norteamericana.
De hecho, durante su visita Nancy Pelosi se
reunió con los mandamases de TSMC, el mayor
fabricante de chips del mundo, al tiempo que
el senador por Massachusetts, Ed Markey se
reunió con responsables de la empresa para
discutir inversiones y formas de mejorar las
cadenas de suministros de chips.
Ese era uno de los puntos clave de la visita.
Y no solo eso, el propio gobierno de Tsai-In-Weng
- galardonada, por cierto, con el premio VisualPolitik
- considera que hoy por hoy esta dependencia
internacional de los chips es la mejor garantía
para la supervivencia de Taiwán.
El problema es que la industria china también
necesita chips.
De hecho el gigante asiático importa más
chips que petróleo.
Tan sólo en 2021 importó chips por valor
de 430 mil millones de dólares.
El 36% procedieron de Taiwán.
De esta forma la carrera por Taiwán se ha
convertido también en una carrera por los
chips más avanzados.
C3("Quien domine el mercado mundial de chips
tendrá la supremacía tecnológica y, también,
militar.
Para las dos grandes superpotencias es un
asunto de supervivencia en su condición de
tales.
Josep Piqué, Director de la revista "Política
Exterior".)
Así qué ya lo veis, en este peligroso juego
un posible bloqueo chino de la isla formosa
es un riesgo real.
No solo como medida de presión contra Taiwán,
sino llegado el caso, también contra Washington.
Así que aquí tenemos otros dos buenos motivos
que explican tanto interés repentino por
Taiwán.
Por un lado, la ocupación de Taiwán le permitiría
a China hacerse con una de las industrias
y tecnologías más importantes del mundo.
Por otro, la ocupación o, incluso, la amenaza
de bloquear la isla le puede dar un enorme
tanto diplomático.
Sería, llegado el caso, un elemento de presión
brutal contra Estados Unidos, Europa y el
resto del mundo.
China podría cortar o al menos amenazar con
cortar la cadena de suministros de chips.
Y eso, eso son palabras mayores.
Pero amigos, aún no hemos terminado.
La pregunta ahora es:
¿A qué escenario nos enfrentamos?
¿Realmente veremos un intento de invasión
en el corto plazo?
¿Cómo puede protegerse Taiwán?
Pues…
¡Atentos!
T3(UNA ARMADURA CONTRA LA PERSISTENCIA DE
PEKÍN)
Con todo lo que hemos visto podemos esperar
que las amenazas chinas no se detengan.
Y esto pone sobre la mesa varias cuestiones.
La primera es,., ¿qué puede hacer Taiwán
para disuadir a China de pasar de la retórica
a la acción?
Es algo de lo que ya os hemos hablado.
Lo primero que tiene que hacer Taiwán es
hacer que cualquier posible invasión se convirtiera
en un enorme quebradero de cabeza.
Es lo que se conoce como la estrategia del
puercoespín.
(Si algo nos muestra la guerra de Ucrania
es precisamente que la guerra asimétrica
utilizando sistemas móviles como los misiles
antitanque Javelin o los misiles antiaéreos
Stinger puede ser, si estos se despliegan
en grandes cantidades, tremendamente eficientes
contra fuerzas mucho mejor equipadas.
Por eso cada vez son más los expertos en
el campo militar que dicen que esto es precisamente
lo que tiene que hacer Taiwán: prepararse
a fondo para una guerra asimétrica a gran
escala: misiles, drones, helicópteros, plataformas
de disparo, sistemas antiaéreos, artillería
de precisión, minas, torpedos....
Equipos por lo general relativamente baratos
que llegado el caso resultarían mucho más
efectivos que carísimos submarinos o tanques.
Asimismo, también, tendrían que prepararse
para entrenar a una parte creciente de su
población.
Esto se podría lograr promoviendo clubes
de tiros o formando una especie de guardia
territorial.)
Claro que eso no elimina ni el riesgo de bloqueo
ni tampoco el daño económico que la creciente
hostilidad con China le puede causar.
En esta línea, reforzar la asociación con
sus aliados internacionales, tanto desde el
punto económico como militar se convierte
en un paso imprescindible.
Precisamente por eso, Taiwán ha pedido la
adhesión al CPTPP y está negociando un acuerdo
de libre comercio con Estados Unidos.
Taiwán tiene que convertirse, desde cualquier
punto de vista, en el mejor aliado de Estados
Unidos, Europa, Japón y el resto de países
aliados.
Sea como sea quizás la mejor noticia es que,
por ahora, la guerra de Ucrania puede haber
frenado, al menos por un tiempo, la enorme
ambición de Xi Jinping.
Ucrania ha demostrado que las cosas pueden
terminar siendo muy diferentes a como fueron
con Crimea y Hong Kong, cuando la comunidad
internacional apenas reaccionó.
Y eso, eso es una extraordinaria noticia para
Taiwán.
Con todo, no parece probable que el objetivo
de China sea intentar una invasión en un
futuro próximo.
(Probablemente el objetivo de Pekín sea algo
más elaborado y se parezca mucho más a lo
que se hizo con Hong Kong: esto es, incrementar
su influencia económica sobre la isla mientras
incrementa y prepara su fuerza militar para
llegado el caso amenazar con un bloqueo y
buscar concesiones para un proceso de integración
progresivo.)
Eso sería algo así como la trampa perfecta,
y por eso, a Xi Jinping y a su gobierno les
irrita tanto que Taiwán está volviendo a
estrechar lazos con Occidente.
De hecho, la creciente retórica china podría
buscar también elevar el riesgo país de
Taiwán para castigar su economía y sus lazos
con occidente.
Así que teniendo todo esto en cuenta el escenario
más probable es que la retórica china vaya
a más y no a menos con el paso del tiempo..
Pero llegados hasta aquí turno para ti:
¿Qué crees que hará finalmente China con
Taiwán?
¿Incrementará sus amenazas o, en cambio,
buscará rebajar la tensión para aproximarse
a la isla?
¿Será el Congreso del Partido Comunista
el punto de inflexión para que las cosas
cambien?
Y seguramente la pregunta más importante
de todas: ¿Qué debe hacer la comunidad internacional?
Dejanos por aquí abajo tus impresiones y
abramos debate.
Como siempre si este vídeo te ha resultado
interesante no olvides darle a like y suscribirte
a VisualPolitik si es que aún no lo has hecho.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.